hello chess lovers hope you're having a
great day
we are here again on a cool well
actually kind of sunny
wednesday and you um you know what day
it is
give stl day so um
per usual we've i think over the last
few weeks
we've been asking for your support for
our uh geva steal day and today is that
day
today is the last day so
please go ahead take a look see if you
want to do anything to show your love
and support for us
we are almost reaching our goal i
believe our goal is about 1500 and we
were last time i checked on 1100
something so go ahead and join
this um cool idea to
basically show us that you love us and
you support us
and you appreciate us and all those kind
of cool stuff
so um yeah please go ahead and do that
and as suggested in
the video we are going to be doing some
games of magnus
i am skeptical if we can do more than
one game because it's just
such cool games i don't really want to
rush through them uh
but however i do have tea carbonated
water with caffeine cold coffee
and lemonade so i am ready so
yeah um also also per usual keep in mind
that we intend to do the switch to
twitch segments
when we're done here so um
in about an hour or hour and a half
depending on how the class is flying
we are going to be wanting to um
switch to twitch and analyze your games
so
start thinking about what kind of games
you want to show and
yeah all right let's go ahead and get
started hi
hi brian yeah gmpg is also very excited
he's kind of just
chilling with the weather looking
outside i kind of i kind of showered him
this week so we had that little um
disagreement going on but i think i've
been forgiven all right let's go ahead
so uh this is a game between carlson and
nakamura
back in 2013 which
feels so so like yesterday but
it's like actually eight years ago
so this makes me feel so old
alright um we have a cool sicilian going
the first thing that i kind of want to
ask is um
well what how what type of game do you
think this is going to be
tactical strategical i know that it's
too early to actually
um ask these type of questions but what
do you think
i am reading a chat so
what do you think also for the students
uh in the chat
how do you feel about semester bending
so soon
in about a week some some people are
almost done some people are all
two weeks left yeah for me my
final final is next thursday
it is kind of classic sicilian i agree
with that so does that mean we're gonna
have like a very chill game or crazy
bang bang taco stuff
oh it's actually kind of tasty
all right um yeah the cat
is oh my god he's being too cute she's
just looking at me and then looking at
the window and
he's the best so yeah um
i don't think this is going to be too
strategic
because well let's look well of course
to be honest i've also seen this this
game
to be able to select it so i kinda know
it's not gonna be
that's um too chill but all right
so um yeah
knife e5 is the best lines there are
knight c6 ideas as well
uh when it comes to like kalashnikov but
knight b5s make the most sense
yeah uh mr z i think you're having a
little error error going on i hope you
can fix it
um
yeah magnus does like to grind and or to
play something to take the point out of
her yeah i agree with that brian
all right so i think this idea with
knight b5 when it comes to kalashnikov
is the best one there are again there
are
different different ways that black can
play this knight of 6
earlier that's one way but again i had
this
it's way too early to start criticizing
opening choices
all right so i kind of want to get a
general idea so
after uh keep in mind if this a6 was
played now
knight d6 is a possibility
it's playable but i don't i if i
remember correctly
this is known to be fine for both sides
so usually white doesn't necessarily um
get too worried with this a6
um but after knight b5
d6 all right so what do you think white
should do this is kind of interesting
because the move that magnus played
is not the main move the main move is
something with c4
or something with like getting night
outs ah not that whoa
not the getting a knight out something
like that that's not what magnus did
c4 is the move that i always play
because
um well why not
uchiha um
i mean i feel like anyone who has
resources support and the time
and if i don't forget motivation they
can
mr z i'm not sure what's up with you
that's i think that it's not a zoo man
all right uh what do you think white
should divide this here
any suggestions
bishop c4 interesting
but usually in this type of openings
with by kalashnikov
or um we don't really
get this bishop c4 idea a lot and
the problem is when you play this bishop
c4 first of all bishop
v6 second of all you kind of want to
keep your options open regarding this
bishop
because uh i actually can't remember a
single game where this bishop has been
elected well actually
um usually this bishop is on the way but
sometimes you can
get this bishop out and kind of form
some sort of attack i remember i've seen
a game
or two like this very long time ago
but that's kind of one of the ideas that
can be presented
let's see um knight one c3 yeah yeah i
think
getting the knight to c3 or like
something like oh not that
it's not like a c4 these are the normal
normal
moves to do if you were to play
something like
knights here a6 knight a3 that's
something that could
easily happen as well
all right so uh in the game
magnus gonna get a special about some
some way right he went for g3
um what do you think about this move and
what do you think black should do
to be honest this bishop is like the
black sheep i guess that's the
expression of white's position so
white would like to try and get this
bishop
somehow potentially to f5
a lot of the times players play
something with like h4 and get the
bishop out there they want to exchange
it
um sometimes they start like this ideas
with queenish five it's it's
a whole different type of uh dynamic but
evan
anyways they want to exchange this
bishop they want to exchange this bishop
any way they can
that's that that's what i was trying to
say yeah
so what do you think black should do
black knows what white wants what do you
think black should do
i'll tell you a little bit about the
either
they like the history or like the the
situation surrounding the move that
black did so it's kind of funny because
after the game when they started to
um talk about like
why black like if magnus had prepared
for this
move that black did or not uh he kind of
said that yeah i
i had i had this like feeling that he
was nakamura was gonna play this move
here even though there were like bunch
of other lines that he could have done
uh magnus was very like lasker and
he had this like a really cool uh
instinctive
like instinctive like grasp yeah grasp
on practical chest psychology yeah kind
of sensing what the opponent
was thinking i've done that like i feel
like sometimes i also have that
idea when i'm playing someone i think
the
the most the most
yeah the coolest one that i want to talk
about
was like when i was playing those
championships there were a few games
that i like
had a feeling what the opponents were
going to play like my first round
i had a feeling that um sabina was not
going to just play some cool
some just like very blub line she would
like play this london
and she did so i had something prepared
against it or when i played
jennifer jennifer you amazing player she
i had a feeling just because she had
played this idea with h6 g5
prior to her game versus against mine
she would like if she was tempted enough
at my bishop on g5 she might have played
this like h6 and then g5 again
which she did so i that's a very oh well
i guess in that sense
i am like carson and laska yes
so yeah overall that's kind of the idea
to try to
be able to predict or have a good
estimation of what your opponent wants
even before the game starts yeah
and yes you guys are actually correct
this h5
was the idea yeah
now what do you think white wants to do
what the whites should do right now this
ideas with like h4 bishop h3
um it's not gonna be as appealing
anymore because there is no more queen
h5
so what do you think we should do here
as white
what do you think okay i think all right
i think oh master z got it
this idea with knight c3 might be the
most appealing one
at least for the time being you're kind
of just
um forcing black to weaken
his queen side yeah and it's
very much worth thinking about i think
this idea with knight citrine is yeah
it's very very appealing
yeah if now black tries to kick this
knight away
now that's something that we actually
like okay so black did play this a6 i
have to play this knight a3
and now b5 now what should we do here as
white keep in mind this b4 is about to
pop up
i'm going to see if i can give you any
more insight on
what went in magnus's brain
in this game
i like this idea of my d5
you have limited choices so let's make
sure we
make it count
okay so one thing that i think is
definitely worth
considering is that
well what are we gonna do with our kink
this d5 square is super weak i agree
with that
c file is also kind of weakened
knight e2 with idea would to juice
to push pawn to f4 um i think that's
way too early in like future could that
could be a possibility
okay so a little background to give you
is like this pawn structure apparently
magnus tempted the
naka to do the similar pawn structure
in an earlier tournament tall memorial
the same year 2013 so that's kind of
like a
um yeah so like this was it in english
and
naka played like a fiance line and
um yeah that didn't really work
and then the d-pawn was in deep deep
trouble
all right all right so now knight d5 was
played obviously knight d5 was
easy to do now let's look at the
improvements if not b5
if knight f6 then what
there are lines such as knight f6 h4
and b5 these are kind of the three main
lines to be mentioned
um so the thing with knight f6 is there
is no h6 so yep bishop g5 exactly
clear example of weak squares yep that's
one of those ones going to be fun
now what about this h4 idea what would
we do here as
white now
i don't think bishop g2 is a wrong move
i think bishop g2 is kind of your best
shot
i think some a move such as
i've been having trouble talking a
little fast recently
knight c4 yeah i think this idea with
knight c4 is also quite interesting
you just begin to add pressure after
pressure
so i think after h4 bishop g2 go it's
the
most logical one if h3 alright i'll just
bring it back
if you try b5 now knight d5 and
again this cool bishop g5 idea
and that's that's kind of the way that
um that was kind of one of the
ideas that magnus had if
naka did go for this h4h3
um yeah
now what do you think okay rp8 this is
kind of going too off topic but i really
do want
to talk about it for a little bit what
do you think about long castle good idea
bad idea
because i think this position before
black played
e5 when we're talking about b5 or knight
f6
or h4 i think that's very critical to be
able to actually
um understand what's going
on
okay okay put pressure on the d-pawn
okay yeah i like it i'm glad that you
guys
are a fan of this castle uh
short castle is a little scary honestly
i don't know if that's what we want to
be doing
yeah i don't i don't really support this
short castle this one is way too
advanced
and i don't really have it's comparing
shortcast of the long castle i'm gonna
have a better shot at long castle
defending my king and like see that play
is already on my third rank
none of these pawns are close to
achieving that level
so i don't really want to do that i
agree with short
with long castle 97 all right cool i'll
eat this for you
and we'll get the exchange and instead
slightly advantageous end game for
um white yeah
let's see was there anything else i
wanted to mention oh yeah if not
not if just if i don't gift you this
pawn
but i do gift you this what do you think
about this
shall we just take it over here is there
any other moves
and again this is a little um
off topic but i think it's important for
us to be able to
uh keep an open mind and oh my god i'm
getting an ad for sandwiches
and i'm quite hungry actually so
it's so unfair all right
what did you think now
bishop edge tree oh i like that yeah
keep in mind that's something that could
be uh coming up
how about just rook takes d6
what do you think about drip takes d6
yeah i don't think arctis t6 works as
well because
now your rook is kind of a pickle rook
b6 i'll take this
and your rook is still kind of misplaced
and next i'm gonna eat this or i want to
go attack your rook and i don't really
know how you're gonna get out of that
yeah so you guys record extra xt6 is a
bad move bishop h3 is the best one
and if take okay i'll just bring it over
and this is again
a pretty decent end game to play yeah
all right so i'm gonna go back back back
back back
a lot back even more back okay a little
bit more back
all right now uh here again this is not
the
necessarily long game so
let's just keep it um
cool b5 was the move that play was
played in the game but
what about bishop g4 i think it's simply
just f3 you move this guy away and then
it's just the same thing i'm eventually
gonna castle anyways
um yeah
what about knight d4
kind of cut some connection cut some
introduces some new ideas
do you think about this
hey buddy what's up
oh the cat's looking me if you're lucky
enough peachy will join our lesson too
yeah bishop g2 great easy peasy you can
just comfortably
comfort to come comfort okay you know
what you can just
easily develop i can't say i can't say
comfort
comfort comfort comfortable comfortable
comfortable oh my god i've lost all my
english
pronunciations i'm just gonna start
talking farsi on the chaplain
good luck for the english viewers all
right b5
now what do you think white should do we
talked about the
we liked knight d5 idea but we didn't
really talk about
what if knight e7 so what if 97
comfortably there we go now i said
um not exactly when i was talking about
bishoprica that was back when the pawn
was on b7 and the other knight went
there
but this is also i mean i guess bishop
g5 is
worth considering but i don't really
like it as much this knight still can
jump jump to d4 the other thing you have
a long term plan
high pitch oh there's a bug
but it's outside so i'm good peach has
been very good
it's killing big bugs it does not catch
mosquitoes though that's very sad
i have to hunt down mosquitoes myself
never move your f pawn in chest that is
not true i
i like moving my fun
under circumstances under right
circumstances
is my cat's name peachy which in farsi
literally means cat
so i it's very creative
i like to see four ideas i think
visually 3 is worth considering
but let's think about your bishops too
um knight c4 no i don't really want to
give up my free night
um yeah
but yeah so um i'm gonna chat a little
while you guys are considering white's
best move so
apparently um in my knowledge the club
is
expanding i haven't really been inside
of the
new site i don't think it's done yet i
think it's plans to open sometime late
summer
again i might be wrong so uh but yeah so
the club isn't we're not
really going to club for this month but
we are hoping to open up from julyish
and it's gonna be fun because a lot of
the junior
senior championships are gonna be held
in person
and in july and then in august late
august we have the
sinful cup going on so i for one
i'm quite excited
okay i think oh i like this idea with
c39c2 i think
that's also a classic sweatshirt of
ideas
to stop knight d4s2 but keep in mind why
did we play this g3 to play bishop g2
right so let's just do this bishop g4
and let's see how it goes uh hi um
vivek yes this is live you caught me
live
i don't know why i just had an image of
a fish being cut
alive but
all right yeah i like the special g2
now let's keep let's keep it still
steady
um i'm not trying to tell you which side
i'm gonna cast though
so this is a game that's in magnus and
naka this is a
this is a big thing right magnus doesn't
it's it's important game he doesn't want
to just
be like i promise i'm gonna shortcast so
i'll be a good boy you can do whatever
you want he's not gonna do that he's
gonna
make you keep wondering and he's gonna
keep some of the mystery alive so
of course he's not gonna immediately
castle either side
unless of those extreme circumstances
like there's a pawn on h3 that kind of
um
limits my options but if i can't if i do
have the choice i'm gonna keep
um keep the choice all right so bishop
g2 what about bishop g4
what shall we do
oh great to be back where are you that's
the morning
we have a few choices either we gotta
block this or
run with this which one would you choose
those are the two choices either queen
going to d3 or pawn going to f3
how long have i been playing chess for
um
whoa uh since i was six
seven so i'm 23 now
yeah i'm getting a lot of mixed ideas
and i'm loving
it
it is india wow one for ben simon
he knows his time zones i have i mean i
knew it would be that side of the world
but
yeah it would be way too early for it to
be iran
i like abstract let's do it uh oh
this is not ben who is it
i don't know my mother ager
wait is this tracy i guess racing
wouldn't
work on wednesdays
anywho um
what about f3 i love it
uh if bishop goes to e6 okay now
there was this idea with c3 and bringing
the knight
i really like that
i think something like c4 is very
misplaced because
we don't know exactly
how this is going to go and i don't want
to we can start weakening on my own
square so let's do the c3
i'm going to keep the square and i have
this idea going on
now what if h4
you want to see my cat oh um there's a
question that's when
the day between queen d2 and queen d3
queen d3
was better but after it was ultimately
better than both of them
the cat is kind of looking at me maybe
but i think it might be a risky business
because he's he
kind of wants to go outside so if i um
play with him too much i'm gonna owe him
okay
here is for the audience
now he might actually sit down
oh he is sitting up good boy
this is actually very good for me
because he's like very fluffy and very
warm so
good for my hands to put on him
yeah eventually we do want to do short
castle
but i don't know if this is the right
time because
well actually it could be
well what do you think about bishop e3
between bishop e3 and castle
kitty okay good
i agree if the castle right now you have
to be prepared for take take
and now i mean this is not that
dangerous honestly
when do you think gm
oh well he wants to take over and
oh boy
boy he got his cuddles it's time for him
to go
honestly i prefer bishop e3 to castell
it's
two because castelling is good but
it kind of makes it too easy for
opponents
why this be very careful this position
yep
oh what about bishop g5 i think this is
definitely doable
but it makes it easier for black so
let's look at maybe bishop g5 first i
think bishop g5 is okay
but
um
um thinking something maybe knight eight
five
would be simply destruct c8 it kind of
makes it too simple
bishop j5 is alright too honestly i
think bishop e3 is ultimately
the um the best one kind of
new stage of development
yeah and if something like tank we take
oh great yeah
this knight is kind of actually kind of
very ironically good here
all right so um in the game magnus made
a slight inaccuracy and he went for
knight c2
castling was alright bishop v3 was okay
bishop going to g5 was also okay but
knight c2 was kind of like a too
casual too too natural yeah
all right in the game nakatuk
we gotta take back
and he went part knight to a5
yeah so what do you think whites did
here ooh
what are we hoping for here
besides for another cat appearance
okay getting the knight out getting the
bishop out i see normal moves i don't i
think they're
all right but let's think if it's black
then what does black wants to do
i think the main problem that white
faces
is that what if black tries to take over
the center with something like f5
g6 maybe take it over here exchange
stuff over here here
hey buddy thank you thank you i i'll
take that i'll
take that clear second
um knight g6
maybe so
i think what black ones ultimately is
this idea with f5 and to try to take
over the center
one way or another so i think what white
should
do is actually what magnus did in the
game
what do you think magnus did in the game
again
something like knight e3 is doable but
it kind of
also blocks the bishop something like
bishop g5
or right but now knight c4 it's
now you have to play b3 because your
phone was under attack
and maybe like uh the h3 and then
eventually this knight will go it so it
can
get a little messy
g4
i don't like this g4
because of knights g6 ultimately this is
going to be a problematic too
f4 thank you brian yeah f4
and magnus did this f4 too
yeah f4 is a great idea
now if knight tries to go to f5 or
take over here which one do you think is
better
to be honest i understand why f4 looks a
little rushed
it just feels like white is really
trying to open the center
when it's not ready when the king is
still in the center so i understand
the concerns
baby
knife f5 minecraft
five right now i have this queen g4 or
even g4
now this works actually i still prefer
queen g for this
then g4 yeah this is cool
um what about this take idea
yeah i think you guys are considering
correct ideas
we do have to take and surprisingly
enough
this is okay the only problem with this
is knight f5 and then you would have
this e6 and it kind of gets a little
messy
so i agree let's just take back on g3
take take and all right
or even just bishop g2 no more funny
business
yeah i like this
white has a little tiny advantage now
naka just played knight
f5 and he's like i'm so done with this i
don't think he actually said that that
loud but
that's the vibe i'm getting now what do
you think we should do
we mentioned this briefly so
yep so that's the thing i i feel like
queen g4 is like a
little little bit safer option that's
why i
felt it more but magnus doesn't do that
she doesn't really play by my rules
unfortunately
he played g4 g more is better
i feel like queen g4 is a little bit
safer with g6 queen street and g4
i thought this is this is again doable
nothing really wrong with it
or you can even like take it over here
take back and this
is perfectly fine um
but black still kind of gets a tiny bit
of edge we don't want to give black that
now what about if not queen g4 what if
queen d3
we already said that g4 is what magnus
did but it's important to understand
why he didn't do these other moves
um when we do switch to twitch it
doesn't have to be
firmly chance but as long as you import
it on leeches on semi leeches like we're
good
okay i think the idea yep g6 thank you
thank you dave
yeah now funny enough you can castle and
just live like this
that's perfectly okay
um knight e3 is another possibility
but it's not exactly good it's kind of
it's just like okay i think it's just i
think
the right word is just reasonable and
it's nothing special
again black still does have like a tiny
bit better but
it's just not what we want when we
have when we have something like g4
consider this position
to when we played g4
to this position of course this is much
more spatial
and white still has much more edge
yeah all right so g4
what do you think is h2 the best move or
should black just move this knight away
so much for king safety right 97 kind of
is funny it's not a good idea at all 97
but white is already plus 2
3. more like straight than two but then
you can just easily do bishop e4
take all this space um
if something like knights g6 i can even
take that
that's how good this position is now
just the amount of development is just
oh this is amazing
almost as good as chocolate all right so
g4
h3 black is fighting back black is
trying to have some queen h4 ideas
what do you think we should do should we
just uh let him take this
or should we move this away
black is toast i kind of agree yeah
knights to e7 also blocks the dark
square bishop
yeah that too yup 97 is not a good
choice
for h3 bishop e4 thank you carlos yeah
bishop e4 is the best one to do
the thing about bishop e4 is that now
if you give me check i
don't it's it looks a little scary but
it's not going to be scary just king f1
if knight goes away to strike g1
if this bishop was in this diagonal okay
now you should be scared actually
you would be dead so no need to be
scared past you past the
scared point
yeah but no um in this position
you don't really need to be scared it's
everything's perfectly fine blacks
pieces are way too misplaced to be able
to form an attack
and yeah the king does look absolutely
ridiculous
but the fun thing is that all of the
squares are under control white pieces
are perfectly fine
you give me few moves and let's say you
play
let's see um i'm going to choose
knight g4 let's say you play
why shouldn't you for you can't just eat
it um
i don't know what what you should do
let's say you play like g6
i can just play la la la la queen e2
next i'm gonna
wanna if you play f5 i'm just gonna eat
this yeah
and then i'm just gonna i can't really
exactly i mean it's
too scary to do that i'm just i'm just
gonna bring it back
pretend to want to give a check want to
attack that
you play e4 i'll just give you a simple
simple simple
what do you think
yeah i think this is this is too good to
actually want to spend too much time on
it so
queenish4 doesn't work what about knight
is for exactly kind of like a fake
castle
artificial castle
what do we think
i guess the main question to answer is
what do i want to do with this guy
am i going to castle it am i going to
just develop my clean side
my d3 interesting
not really
surprisingly enough castle is the best
one
it's simple it's safe um
you're not sure if you're going to be
able to attack anything that i own
yeah and this light is just looking
ridiculous here
it doesn't really have any anything to
do
yeah no we're just going to short castle
yep
this is not a scary position your next
few moves could
be king g1 if needed something like
g5 to cut the connection to between this
knight
too let's see what else can it can there
be
maybe an f5 but you're just gonna try to
push in the king side
yeah short castle is the best and
believe me i know it looks absolutely
ridiculous
but yeah this is um the best one
so is there anything that worries you
right now is there like a move that
you're gonna be like ah if black does
this move i don't know what to do
i wanna start crying
no crying for you
good if there's not quite yeah this
check doesn't really hold any serious
threats
first off king ishwan second one bishop
e3
no no serious threats
so um after castling
what black did in the game was g6
wanna develop it and here
um magnus made the mistake
he played king h1 which is so weird it
shouldn't be a mistake but the problem
is that king ish 1 is
too it's like wasting a move
yeah because now black has this f5
and if you try to go away e4 if you try
to go away
and it's kind of black gets a little bit
of a room to breathe we don't want stats
i agree right this is that's kind of why
i love this position
this game because it's so um
just like i just want to scream like oh
my god
what's happening to my king why is my
king in there why
why why yeah
all right let's go back so
bishop e2 let's not um let's not
get into this f5 problem
um magnus was kind of lucky and the best
move here is actually g5 after g6
you prevent any type of cool f5 as if
you were playing five i'm just going to
be like
take it you take that i'll take this it
looks scary but it's not you take that
and my queen comes up your king is the
one that's weak
because my i have so much more space and
so much more
pieces involved all right
so g5 would be best because black wants
to play f5 so in the game he just played
king h1
bishop g7 and now f5 f5 is good
because after take take now you have
ideas
to get your pieces out and funny enough
black just played knight g2 what do you
think we should do after this knight's
g2
yeah right that alpha song would be
super cool
mighty one okay interesting you really
don't like that light on
g2 now do you
what's the threat absolutely nothing
just wanted to advance its position
bishop h6 actually would have been a
better move because now if you take
group g1 it kind of makes more sense you
get rid of that bad bad
bad bishop
yeah hi
[Music]
well yeah so nigeria absolutely does not
really have any serious stress
what do you think we should do now
f6 yes love it bishop f8
uh keep in mind taking it was not really
a good choice i would just play this
and this would be winning because of f7
okay so bishop f8 now again queen f3
trying to defend over here now what do
we do
we know we have advantage just how can
we bring in more pieces
bishop g5 interesting interesting
night before good one finally let's get
this knight involved as well
now if you try to also include your
knight awesome
you try to bring your knight to attack
my bishop now what do i do with this
bishop
um knight d3 was alright but tonight b4
is just
makes more sense yeah we just want to
get that knight in the game
asap
i agree dave that we should try to move
the bishop but i don't agree with the
direction
yep bishop fine you got it and if knight
d7
now what we're approaching final stretch
you know you have killer advantage all
you gotta do is
um knock it out of the park
i guess that's the expression
okay
careful guys you're forgetting you have
more pieces to develop
um taking down history maybe but the
problem is right now you're kind of
forgetting about your bishop again
yeah bishop g5 defend your pawn
to be honest something like bishop e4
also is
doable but then knight c5 again and then
you do the same thing again
so let's not do that let's just do the
bishop g5 defend my pawn
now if rick g8 my bishop is under attack
how can i
go about this
i agree let's just get the queen out too
quinji for a little um i think
problematic
taking over here yeah i was thinking
maybe 93
but standards is checked so not that
just
9 6. yeah careful nine queen queenish
five
greenish five keep the queen engaged as
possible you have so many many many
threads
okay let's say knight b6 as mentioned
previously bishop d6 i'm going to go
after your goodies
tank take take and take now
here it's actually kind of funny because
black actually resigned he couldn't take
the pain anymore
completely understandable it's a very um
sad position
yeah so yeah uh this was how
magnus beats naka in 2013
there has i mean these two have played
so many times over the years
i don't think anyone can pick a favorite
but this one is definitely among one of
my favorite ones because
just look at the final position it's so
cool
take check my threads check my threads
check my threads let's see any other
checkmate tricks
it's just so cute yeah
so uh this is the end of our youtube
session so
uh please like subscribe leave comments
i tried to leave
to read them but whenever i get a chance
and also don't forget that today is the
last day for
give santos give stl day so please
donate and the link below to san luis
chess club
we are trying to reach a goal of 1500 we
are above 1100
at the moment so it's not it's
quite doable actually um also also
please we are gonna do our segment of
switch to twitch
so um have your games ready and off
in a format of a leeches link and send
them to me
in about 10 minutes we're gonna be live
on twitch
so send them to me on our twitch chat
and again like subscribe comment
share all right awesome i'll see you
guys